[Music]
all right we're gonna do a little bit of
uh advice today Jennifer says hi Matt
I'm married to a wonderful conservative
man and he and I are on the same page
and almost everything and share the same
values we're both in our mid-20s and
getting ready to have kids but I have
one problem I'd like to try and solve
before we do my dear husband smokes weed
and uh I really don't want him to be
doing that once we have kids or while
we're trying for that matter because I
know smoking can impact fertility he
doesn't smoke very frequently a couple
of days a week but it's enough to bother
me I know we used to smoke in his teen
years but he stopped and didn't smoke
for most of the time we were dating and
engaged so I didn't really think it was
a problem before marriage how should I
go about approaching him about this
without potentially causing issues
oh there's no way to approach it except
to just tell him everything you've told
me the only issue it he might not want
to hear it but I think it's perfectly
valid for you to raise it especially
especially if
from what you're telling me when you
knew him and you were engaged and you
first got married he wasn't he didn't
have this this weed habit um so it's so
he can't say that oh this is something
that you knew about and now you're now
you're now you're switching up on me so
this is a change that apparently from
what I'm getting from this he has made
since you got married
which um gives you all the more reason
to object
and I I'd feel the same way about it you
know I know that there are plenty of
people who smoke weed and they get very
upset you know when we um if there's any
criticism made against it and generally
the the well you'll hear from from them
is that well it's no different what's
the difference between smoking a little
bit of weed or like having a drink at
the end of the day having a beer What's
the difference
um I think that there is a difference
you know on a few different levels one
one is like the psychological effect
that marijuana can have and uh and it
can have it in a more sort of potent way
now obviously alcohol if you if you
overdo it and you get drunk then that
has all kinds of physical and
psychological effects and that's no good
but I think that the psychological
effect of marijuana even used casually
is much more potent and pronounced and
there have been plenty of studies done
linking marijuana to things like
schizophrenia and those sorts of things
those studies are out there and I also
think it's like it's it's less of a
social you know you you if you're in a
social environment you're all sitting
down you have you have a couple of
drinks it's like a it's a it's a social
thing and it opens you up to be a little
bit more so again as long as you're not
overdoing it
kind of as a social lubricant whereas
marijuana is not that it kind of brings
you in to yourself it's a very it's more
of an isolating thing
which would make it all more of a
problem in the context of a marriage or
if you have kids
and so I think
all you could do is just communicate
this to him and say that this you're not
comfortable with this in the house
and you've ever read say that takes a
special kind of company to want to
partner with my show you know I say a
lot of things that make a lot of people
angry and this tends to scare off
advertisers I will admit that's why I'm
so grateful for partners like pure talk
who stand behind me and my show no
matter the consequences they might face
Pure Talk shares my values which is why
we've made them the official cell phone
wireless partner of the daily wire
that's not the only reason Pure Talk
offers the most Dependable 5G Network in
the US I use it myself their plans are
top tier but at a fraction of the cost
of ATT Verizon or T-Mobile you get
unlimited talk text and unlimited data
with a mobile hotspot for just 55 a
month you vote how you spend your money
so stop supporting woke wireless
companies that don't support you instead
go to puretalk.com Walsh you'll get
great coverage and you'll save while
you're doing it when you go to
pre-ertalk.com Walsh you can save an
additional 50 off your first month
because they actually value you imagine
that that's puretalk.com Walsh Pure Talk
Wireless us for Americans by Americans
all right here's one from
Reddit
interesting one says I've been divorced
from my ex-wife for seven years we were
together for eight before that and
married for four years we have two
children together ages 14 and 12. we
co-parent and each get our own week with
the children
I love my wife deeply but the sad truth
is that she couldn't stay away from the
male attention she's a very beautiful
woman she has been her whole life men
would always look when they walked by
and I used to think how lucky I was that
she was mine till I found out she was
entertaining these men as well I had
found texts in her phone multiple times
I let go of that because it was over the
phone
that was a mistake then I'd find out
that she allowed them to take her on
dates or to bars secretly after her work
shift ended she promised it was never
sexual yeah okay and I never had any
proof that it was but who knows well no
we know we all know it was
um she said that she just liked the
compliments and the idea of how many
guys like to pay attention to her and it
gave her some weird high that wasn't my
cup of tea so I ended the marriage so
he's free I'm already seeing some of the
problems here the way that he's even
phrasing this is so passive yeah it
wasn't my cup of tea you know having a
wife cheat on me wasn't really my cup of
tea wasn't my thing uh no I tried it out
and didn't really like it that just
makes you a beta cook um she spent the
last years in therapy in which she has
been diagnosed with histrionic
personality disorder and OCD she claims
she's doing really well at our last drop
off with the kids she told me that she
told her therapist that she'd like to
reconcile her marriage a year ago and
she hasn't been on any dates or tried to
be flirtatious she said that her goal
was to fix us that she wanted to be a
family again if I was willing to try
knowing she has a diagnosis for why she
wants this attention so badly and her
actively getting help to contain these
behaviors opens my mind up greatly if
the possibility of a happy marriage but
I'm also not fully sure that I can trust
her I want nothing more than my family
back but I don't want a repeat of the
first time
yeah um this is an interesting one
because you know first of all I would
never
discourage someone from trying to repair
a marriage especially when you have kids
if there's a way to repair a marriage
and reconcile then you know that's
always ideal and it's a beautiful thing
but there are a bunch of red flags in
this case
um aside from the obvious ones that she
was cheating but
you know some of this is like the timing
of it so they've been divorced for seven
years
um and while they were together she was
out you know it was in sexual it was I
was just flirting with other men yeah
sure but what that tells me is that she
says she's 37 years old now
and so she's getting older and you know
as you get older I'm 37 you're still
young you know it's like I'm only 36 but
as you get older your looks start to
fade a little bit you don't have the
same kind of youthful beauty that you
once had and so this tells you that's
something that's part of what's going on
here which would mean that it's like
it's less likely that there was a
conversion moment
people can be reformed they can change
that seems less likely here and more
likely that the attention is drying up
from all the random guys
and she was getting a lot more attention
in her 20s and she's 90 her 20s anymore
and so now and she's starting to feel
lonely and so that's why she is going
back Crawling Back to the uh to the
ex-husband which would tell us that
they're that there there's a good chance
there wasn't any actual uh personal
reference Reformation that happened and
then the other big one another big red
flag this kind of hiding behind a
diagnosis
and the diagnosis makes her feel better
and it makes the ex-husband feel better
because they say oh well that explains
it that's why you were act that's why
you were dis you were a disloyal liar
you were a horrible disloyal Unfaithful
woman
it's only because you were it's because
you had histrionic personality disorder
and OCD
depends all you just what you had to get
some therapy you take some drugs for
that and you're fine you're cured
no that's not the way it works you know
we cannot medicalize everything all
right uh well we can I mean we have
medicalized everything but we shouldn't
and people make choices they make
decisions they do things
there are things called character flaws
you know there are sins there are evil
choices people make all that exists
and that's what happened here
is that flirting with other men is not a
a symptom of a mental disease
it is a choice that you made is is it
it's a symptom of a Character defects
and your own choices your own you had
reasons that you chose to act that way
because you like the attention you know
there's it's it's they're actually kind
of rational bad reasons but rational
there's a rationale behind it it's not
like it was psychotic behavior you like
attention that's why you acted that way
and the fact that she goes and and goes
for the the diagnosis
and take some comfort in being diagnosed
that way that only tells me that
actually she has not been willing to
confront what she actually did because
she doesn't want to admit that she did
these things and she made these choices
she wants to she wants to believe that
oh it was all it was all the mental
illness doing that
so
I don't think that there's uh there does
not appear to be at this point a chance
of any real reconciliation for those
reasons unfortunately and I'll do it for
us so we'll talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed
thank you